hello there you're watching the press
preview first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive
in the next half hour we'll see what's
making the headlines with the consultant
editor of the daily mail
andrew pearce and the associate editor
of the daily mirror kevin mcguire lovely
to see you guys and we'll get your
choices in a moment but first
let's see what's on the front of some of
those papers the ft
leads with a recommendation from the
uk's advisory committee on vaccines that
people
under 30 should be offered alternatives
to the oxford astrazeneca jab
after rare instances of people in that
age group suffering blood clots having
received it
it's also the top story for the eye
their headline astrazeneca jab ruled out
for the under-30s the guardian points
out that the news couldn't dent public
confidence
in the vaccine on that school the
telegraph speaks to the family of a 59
year old solicitor who died of a blood
clot on the brain
having been given the astrazeneca jab
they're urging people to keep taking
it in order to save lives keep calm and
carry on jabbing is the headline in the
mail which says scientists and
politicians
are all calling on people not to reject
the vaccine
the sun highlights the very low chances
of developing a blood clot
after receiving the jab and away from
the vaccine the metro reports on the
additional rail services being laid on
as we emerge
from lockdown well let's talk through
those front pages with andrew pierce and
kevin mcguire
lovely to see you both um the vaccine uh
really dominating most of the front
pages still
the daily mail andrew your paper
starting with keep calm
and carry on jabbing that that is the
message from
the scientists is the message from the
government but are the population
listening
i think they are you know jane because i
think they realize as you pointed out in
the introduction
79 uh blood clots uh associated with the
astrazenec zeneca jab
20 million people have had that jab that
is a very very very small number
um euros more likely to be uh and only
i think nine was it 19 of them were
fatal
uh uh you're far more likely to be
killed in a in a road accident
uh it's still infinitesimal really and
we've got to stay
confident stay true to the vaccine
program they've
taken up the precaution of saying that
people under 30
who are more at risk from these clots uh
should be given alternative vaccines but
unfortunately we've got the modern one
coming on stream
there's more vaccines being developed
because we are so well advanced with our
vaccine program
and i think we as as corporal jones
would have said in dad's army don't
panic don't panic there's no need to
panic
and um and i think there's evidence that
the
number of vaccinations done today was up
sharply again
i think the british public are confident
and reassured
and it's interesting isn't it that the
european medicines regulator
didn't even recommend people under 30
shouldn't be using
the astrazeneca vaccine they just said
um we should make the point that
there can be rare conditions of blood
clots
there's some suggestion isn't there too
jane that um
that it is more likely to affect women
uh women under the age of 30 and that
that could
possibly be linked to them potentially
being on
the pill well yes because there's a risk
to that in itself isn't there which
which a lot of women yeah on a daily
basis will just take that risk
and continue to take take the
contraceptive and kevin the sun also
going with this line and they've got uh
a really clear
graphic on their front front with with a
picture of a syringe
and 0.0095
chance of a killer clot and that and
that's certainly something we've been
trying to reflect on sky news today we
you know ed conway's been trying to
explain the difference between the risks
of the vaccine and the risks of not
taking the vaccine
um do you think the media is doing a
good job of explaining this story
without scaremongering
i think so actually uh jen you know
some newspapers never get it right all
newspapers rarely get to
get it right but i i agree with the
daily mail
i keep calm and carry on jabbing and i
like that sum from paige as well because
i mean those odds that 0.000
that's probably the uh the odd the
chances of uh
of andrew pierce buying
it's just really not going to happen
it's very it's so
unlikely but i can i could see why they
came clean i thought i thought that was
really good the regulator
is working and that they didn't try to
hide
the fact there is this very rare very
exceptional
side effect they thought right let's get
it out into the open that ends
or will curb some speculation
by just being upfront about it and then
changing what's going to happen with the
under
with the under 30s and offer them
something
something else because they might be a
group that is hesitant but
younger people tend to feel they're
immortal they're going to live forever
and nothing will
will happen to them we've got so far why
do we need the
need the vaccine well there's still a
risk then because you want everybody
vaccinated
so you don't pass it on to other people
it's not just about about yourself so
i think i think there has been a fair
degree of responsibility and i i can
often be
a great critic of the media and
newspapers and some newspapers in
particular but
from what we've seen tonight i think
it's well
this is the position it's a surprise
some people shock
some people some people will be
concerned others will be they'll be
worried but it's putting it in context
and
you're quite right the great uh killer
is the virus which on the official toe
is called nearly 127
000 people the the killer
is the vaccine that is your savior but
every every
medicine has some side effects you you
buy
um some aspirin or paracetamol
and god the uh you pull out a bit of
paper and it goes on and on and on
telling you how it might damage you but
people take it and
it it's overall impact is uh is really
good i suppose andrew the other the
other benefit is
that most under 30s will will not have
had the vaccine it will only have been
those who are in
any of those particular high risk groups
so also
the regulations are working in the sense
that they found that this is an issue
before this key group
actually had major access to it
yeah i mean they're they're probably
some weeks away still uh and
and and what's really reassuring is the
government are arguing that we're still
on target to have
all that all adults vaccinate give them
at least one vaccine or even two
vaccines
by the end of july um yeah and very few
people under the age of 30 would have
been
exposed even to this tiny risk of a
potential blood clot
and fantastic news that the modern
vaccine has been rolled out today
starting in wales
uh there's another one being developed
in scotland and
uh and they will be immune from the
clutches of the european union which is
still
huffing and puffing about will they or
won't they impound
astrazeneca vaccines in europe destined
for britain
but i suspect and it was reassuring that
the european medicines regulators have
said hasn't
um suggested even people under 30
shouldn't be having astrozenica vaccine
it's still a great triumph of british
science and
and great cooperation with europe too
uh and uh and and i still think we are
going
great guns gangbusters on the vaccine
rollout program
and it's the key to everything isn't it
we're starting to sense
normality returning change starting to
sense the economy might start picking up
again
hey you never know we might be able to
go on holiday
just bring in the front of the guardian
as you as you talk kevin because
they're also going with this story about
jab confidence
um you you you wanted to get in there
yeah no i think jab confidence is is an
issue
and i think everybody involved the nhs
scientists
even some politicians have to keep
saying look
this is it's safe for all intents and
purposes
it is safe to have the astrazeneca
vaccine what is not safe
is to be unjabbed to not get immunized i
think that
must have been pressed home time after
time after but um i just wanted to point
out to andrew
the modern vaccine that was used in
wales today was imported
from speed and
time and i know he just loves to promote
brexit and bash everything to do with
the european union
every time uh concerns were raised
in the european union about the uh
astrazeneca
vaccine he was claiming it was all about
brexit well
i think now concerns have been raised in
the uk
over blood clots i'm not sure every
government in the european union
acted uh responsibly when they suspended
use but you could see some of those
concerns
were far more legitimate than andrew
gave them credit for at the time
andrew are you concerned about the
international reputation of the
astrazeneca vaccine because
the key to to the whole world getting
back to normal
is as many people having it and if this
is the one that was destined for all of
those developing countries
being made at cost if those developing
countries lose confidence in it
that's a big problem for all of us isn't
it it is and remember yeah and
astrazeneca in the one of the greatest
acts of philanthropy known
in modern times really giving selling
this drug
at cost price it was going to be hugely
important in the developing world in
africa
call it the third world whatever you
will but um i think we've just got to
stay
stay confident about the fact the
european medicines regulator has said
it's very rare uh the blood clots are
very rare same with the british medical
regulator
but as for you know european union
leaders kevin knows full well that
president macron behaved like a complete
idiot over the astrazeneca vaccine
saying that people over a certain age
shouldn't use it and when he then had to
concede he didn't have a grain
of scientific evidence for it likewise
angela merkel
they have caused big problems with their
utterances here in this country we've
allowed the scientists to
proclaim and pronounce on the efficacy
of this vaccine
again and again and they've done it
today and the politicians follow suit
in france and germany unfortunately it
was the politicians mouthing off
when they had no evidence to support
their assertions
um jane i did i did think today it was
better
that experts gave their view uh
and and put it out in a very objective
way than say
having for instance the prime minister
boris johnson coming back from
cornwall to to lead it because he's
should we say he's often a stranger to
the truth so his word would not have
been taken i think the way
somebody like jonathan van tan the
deputy chief medical officer in uh
in england who i think is the most
effective communicator
of any any of the experts who stand
there
at the front of the front of the
telegraph tomorrow um has
it's leading on the family of a clock
victim say keep taking the astrazeneca
vaccine so again
not an expert but somebody who has seen
at the sharp end what what the the
negative impacts of this potentially can
be but but also see the bigger picture
yeah i think i think that's an important
piece actually because it's solicitor
neil
he worked for warrenton uh borough
council and it's his sister dr allison
hostiles who
there's a pharmacologist at uh
huddersfield university
who says look uh her brother was
extraordinarily unlucky
and she wants people to keep getting
vaccinated because
breath from the virus it is not the
vaccine and i've
given given she must still be grieving
the loss of
of her brother it must have taken a fair
bit
just to speak out like this but it's
important
she has he is the only victim we know
who's been named of those 19 who died
yeah desperately sad and a difficult
time to talk to the media as well
guys thank you very much we've got lots
more to come after the break we'll be
discussing
about whether the rail services could
get back on track
after lockdown stay tuned
we are seeing uh actually a quite a
small eruption
this is uh one of the smallest yet but
how big it will be in the end is
anyone's guess
because this is what's called uh
it's very coming from deep this magma is
what's called very primitive coming
right from the mantle of the earth and
in
there are cases when eruption like this
can go on for long
but this is placed
nearer to the population centers of
iceland it is
30 kilometers from reykjavik it's
close to some town or 10 kilometers from
the town
on the south coast so volcanic activity
in this
area is much closer to most of us than
most of the volcanic activity in iceland
there's a major uh
i pray operation ongoing uh
trying to secure the security of
people that go into the area uh
there is uh there are dozens of rescue
group people present and it's organized
and
and by the local police and civil
protection
and there are and it's all meant to
try to secure that nobody is harmed but
there is an enormous interest in this
this is spectacularly beautiful
and if people do things in the right way
there isn't much danger the problem is
if you go too close
if you go under a wall of of of lava
it may collapse there can be gas in in
in pockets the indications are that this
will
go on probably in a similar manner
uh we have no idea how for how long
it can go on for weeks
months and if we look at the geological
past
then we have events in iceland that have
probably gone on for decades
we're not really expecting that but
nature
we don't know what nature is actually
going to do but this has quite some
similarities to the volcanic activity
that is
very common on hawaii
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now andrew pearce and
kevin mcguire taking us through their
choices of the front and inside pages
and the metro's front page this is about
coronavirus but it's about
services getting back to normal andrew
britain's apparently going to get back
on
tracks at last all the royal services
are going to be back up and running
yeah so they're going to be laying on a
lot more trains a lot more
carriages and they're also going to
clean them which will make a
refreshing change because quite often
particularly uh
the train down to bright which i use a
lot the trains are absolutely
rancid and filthy so they're going to
clean them may try and make them more
covered friendly because
more there is evidence now that more
people are starting to go back to work
in offices
evidence of that even in the city of
london which has been deserted
for months and months has absolutely
deserted my dentist is over that part of
london
nobody around at all but it's picking up
a bit now so
it's a sign that trains are coming back
and some things that don't change jane
of course
the affairs on the trains have gone
rocketing up
way above the rate of inflation nothing
new there oh i thought you'd said
affairs i was thinking about brief
encounter
and kevin of course though a lot of
people will have changed how they work
whether there'll be a lot of people who
won't be getting back on the trains
no that's right i think they're unlikely
ever to be as crowded as they were
because of that there'll be
some people who say had office jobs will
do
two three four days five days
rail services were absolutely slashed uh
during lockdown so the mattress says
eighteen thousand back next uh
but it's it is true uh jane that they
are
safer um and tfl in who operates um
trains and tubes and buses in london
imperial college does tests and they
just have no
trace of covert which i think is a you
know fantastic testimony to the
the cleaning abilities of t uh tfl staff
and you hope
uh when the virus is gone or just about
gone
that the operators continue to put so
much effort into cleaning public
transport
uh because it will just be better well i
i i do think that a lot of people in
lots of areas of life are going to be
cleaning things really differently now
uh for all of us um final story that you
picked for this half hour and this is an
inside pages of the metro
this is lance martin who lives right on
the edge of a cliff
in norfolk uh he's um he's not going
anywhere though is he andrew
well you wouldn't think so would you uh
and but what might be going somewhere is
his house
because it's teetering on the edge
i mean he knew the risks when he moved
in there didn't he but he's going to
stick it out for as long as he can
i know but he lost 20 feet uh
over easter uh he lost 100 feet when the
beast from the east
uh was creating storms in 2018 so he
paid nearly a hundred thousand pounds
for that place he's got an option to
actually
drag it over the road on a vacant block
which you might
uh you might have to do but uh you
normally sleep soundly but a bit less
soundly now when you are
literally living on a cliff edge i hope
he's okay and
when you say he's not going anywhere i
hope he doesn't go anywhere
i hope that house doesn't go up he
should get the hell out of there
well it's quite a view isn't it well
listen guys thank you very much for
taking us through your choices we will
see you we'll speak to you again at half
past
11 and find out some of your other
choices there thanks a lot